why our exams so hard why do teachers
make exams so hard when I was a student
I asked this question myself and I
didn't really get much of an answer to
it and I think because I didn't
understand why teachers made exams
difficult I was really frustrated and I
got myself into a lot of grief because
of it and I see that happening now
around me as well I see people no one
likes doing hard exams people are really
grieved by hard exams and I think now
that I've become a teacher I've learned
a lot of things that I make sense of why
teachers write hard exams and that's why
I try my best to write exams that are
hard that a challenging and I've come up
with a few reasons which I hope explain
why we do this and also might even give
you reason to actually not just
understand why exams are hard but
actually want them to be hard okay so
I've got five reasons all right and this
is just my opinion
it's not an official stance or anything
but I hope these reasons the reasons
that I've come up with make sense to you
and help okay so here we go
reason number one in exams roar marks
are meaningless okay
here's why this is important when I
supervise an exam and I'm finishing it
up I'm collecting the papers and as I
leave the exam hall one of the things
that I'll often hear is people saying oh
laughs did you I can't believe how hard
that exam was like I've already lost
seven marks okay or I'll hear things
like I couldn't even do any of the last
question at all max I'm going to get 75%
it was a terrible test okay so people
say that a lot now here's the thing that
you need to get right if you got given a
hard exam right that means everyone in
the grade also got a hard exam so
everyone's going to be hit equally right
now the reason that is important is
because when it comes to why your marks
are important what we do with the marks
if we're for example putting you into
classes on the basis of the marks of an
exam right and I understand people often
you're really stressed out because so
much is writing
on their exam which class they're going
to get to you okay the the important
thing is not the raw mark you get the
important thing is your rec right your
position relative to others in the grade
and so your remark it might be really
really low but so what everyone's right
the important thing is how you perform
with regard to other people that's what
matters for classes and I hope you you
see no matter the difficulty of the exam
they're within reason okay
the rankings of the grade will not
really be affected okay so wrong marks
they're not really that important you
know by the time they get to your report
anyway they have been quite heavily
modified okay so don't don't worry about
raw marks and how an exam make your
remarks really terrible okay roll marks
aren't really quite meaningless okay all
right reason number two easy exams they
don't distinguish skilled levels okay
you think about this will make sense if
we set an exam is super super simple
the questions are it's a short exam and
the questions are very easy and everyone
can do them okay what will happen is you
come out of the exam figure ah that's
great you know I did really well on that
exam but everyone will do really well
the strong students will do well
obviously but the weakest students will
also do very well because the questions
were all so simple or because there was
no time pressure really okay now the
reason why that's a disaster is because
when it comes to us putting you into
classes for example we can't distinguish
between who's who we can't work out
whether you belong in this class or that
class because everyone's marks look the
same when you have an easy exam okay and
so that's that's a lot of good thing now
you might think ah I'll be really glad
if I can slip into ten J instead ten R
or inter you know 12 M to instead 12 M 3
okay but let me try and persuade you
it's not a good thing to be in a class
where really you don't fit because
what's going to happen is all throughout
the year you're just going to find the
people around you will understand the
concepts much quicker than you and
you'll just be lagging behind and when
you ask you want to ask questions you
know the teacher will want to move on
because everyone else has moved on and
you're going to struggle and you'll turn
to your friend next to you and say hey
you know I didn't get this and they'll
be already on to something else and it's
actually a very um a very difficult
thing to be in a class where you're
beyond your limits where you're
exceeding your capacities better to just
be pushing them a little bit than to be
in a place where actually you don't
belong okay and so when a mark that when
exams are hard
they help us put you in the right
classes when questions are just simple
straightforward but have multiple parts
right that get more difficult as you go
then we can tell who can really do the
more difficult things and so who is more
appropriate to go into a higher class
it's a reason number three and it's a
big reason
difficult exams hard exams are learning
experiences hard exams will help you
learn okay so it's one thing to look at
a concept in the program right and say
oh yeah
the chain rule differentiation you know
calculus I understand that and think to
yourself I can do this question right
that's one thing it's another thing
entirely to under exam pressure be able
to recognize that the derivative of
sorry the yeah the derivative of log cos
x is negative 10x okay and to recognize
that when everything is really really
under pressure those are two different
things
right and it's the same in all kinds of
areas of life so for instance it's one
thing to sit back and watch Jamie Oliver
you know cooking a 30-minute meal and it
puts together this delicious Spanish and
ricotta cannelloni
okay it looks really easy it looks
really easy when Benji Marshall throws a
dummy at exactly the right time and
makes a line break it looks it sounds
really easy when got the ASAP sings
somebody that I used to know right he
makes it look very easy but it's another
thing entirely and you you find out when
you actually try it yourself that you
know it's not as easy as it looks
you know you burn the cannelloni your
dummy part is completely unconvincing
and you know your voice cracks when you
try to hit the octave jump in the core
and the point is that you know you learn
your areas of weakness when you actually
test them and difficult exams test them
more than easy ones that make sense so
when you come out of an easy exam you
might think ah hey I'm not so bad after
all that may be true but it doesn't help
you to learn anything you know it
doesn't show you that when you've got a
locus and you've got to square root
expressions from distance equations on
one side of the equation
you can't just square everything out and
hope it's going to come out in the wash
you've got to rearrange things before
you do that or you know when you do the
easy exam it doesn't reveal that if you
don't read the question even it's the
very first paper very very first
question on the paper you're not going
to get the question right because you
weren't paying attention right so
difficult exams will help you learn
because they review your weaknesses
right and so we should learn to in fact
appreciate them let me illustrate this
another way and I owe this illustration
actually to a standard student named Chi
Y so you know if you're out there
watching Gy thanks for this one Jiro is
a runner and sometimes some mornings I
would see him practicing Sprint's out on
the oval and you could recognize him a
mile away because he did something very
unusual when he was sprinting he
actually wore a parachute he strapped a
parachute onto his back and so when he
ran you know it would kick up because of
the air resistance and it would make him
run slower okay now why did he do that
why why would he go to the effort of
making things harder for himself and
he's not the only one I have friends who
play basketball when they train they
strap weights onto their ankles as
they're playing basketball why do they
do that well I take it the reason why
the parachutes and the weights are
something they do to themselves is
because they're voluntarily making
things harder for themselves because
making it harder for themselves
I also get stronger and faster and
enables them when they take off those
constraints to just totally blow away
the competition and perform in a much
higher level
right and hard exams are the same
pushing you to your limits so that when
you do exams which you know when you get
to the actual HSC you'll be fine your
Blitzer right because you've had the
difficult practice okay reason number
four and this is the reason no one likes
to hear but difficult that that
experience that difficulty that you
finally do difficult is relative its
relative okay
if people come out of an exam saying oh
that was crazy you know that was so hard
I felt a rage quitting after ten minutes
okay let's think about this for a second
there are two main plausible reasons why
you had that experience with the exam
now firstly the exam could just have
been really hard okay that's definitely
a possibility there's not the only one
secondly it could be that you and your
grade are just much weaker than you
realize okay now these two aren't
mutually exclusive they can happen at
the same time but I hope you see the
point that when an exam feels difficult
who says it was a difficult exam it
really isn't it possible could it be
that if another graders had this exam
they might not find it difficult
they might just find it average right
couldn't it be that the grade as a whole
just really needs to pull their socks up
and work harder you know the more
difficult questions and complete the
assigned work that we give you you know
couldn't be that really the exam was
just normal and it's about your level of
competence not just that if you were to
the exam now that being said I don't
think the exams you two are easy okay
that's not our intention that sort of in
trying to explain why we do that right
but don't make excuses and don't just
assume it's the exams fault right if you
find the exam difficult don't just
question the exam question yourself as
well right be sobered by the fact that
your marks or a bit lower than your
expected you know there was this
sometimes I something that really
frustrates us is we give you questions
that coincidentally turn up in the exam
the exact same question maybe the
numbers are different right and you
still do poorly on them
well we give you specific advice you
know say in the post-mortem after an
exam and the following exam you continue
to make the same errors right now we all
do that raw human but that's that's
indicating that the fold is not the exam
it's it's that you've got to work hard
at your revision and the effort that
you're putting into it okay so I don't
just blame the exam question yourself as
well because difficulty is relative okay
so um let me review number one I'm war
marks are meaningless number two
easy exams don't sort you right so they
help hard exams help us to tell you
apart number three hard exams help you
to learn now before difficulty is
relative between you know grades and
years lastly most importantly exams as a
whole they're not the most important
thing in life okay
exams are way down the list of the
things that should be important to you
and so for me the one of the biggest
things is that those who respond
negatively to these exams do so almost
universally because they place too much
emphasis on the exam I've seen exams
I've written exams where people leave
the exam hall may shed tears afterwards
okay now I don't mean disrespect and I
don't want to trivialize the difficulty
that you find with these exams but if
any exam makes you cry if it moves you
that emotionally then you've placed too
much importance and emphasis on the exam
is right to view these exams as
important but only so much so that you
put decent effort into them and actually
give it a real go and not just at all
whatever it's an exam you shouldn't view
the exams are so important that they're
really affecting you in that in that
deep way right and causing you grief
okay so if you understand and believe
this reason I think a lot of the other
reasons will fall into place and I hope
that hope that helps you make sense of
why we write hard exams and why you
should appreciate them actually